He was the quiet efficience and Osu ruthless architects of the Holocaust,
Hitler's most loyal sycophants.
He ruthlessly dispatch those seem stood in his way as he rose to eight position
of power that was second only to that of the fear.
At the end,
he spectacularly betrayed his master Oh need to be felt by his own hands.
In this episode of biographics,
we reveal the cold calculating life and the death of Heinrich Himmler.
Heinrich Luitpold Himmler was born on October the seventh 1900 after whistled
Barker Strauss to in Munich.
He was the second of three sons to Gab Hoss and Anna Marie.
Hemlock Gephardt's was the deputy headmaster of land should high school
bandwidths a pious and pedantic man.
The family were well off,
but they weren't rich and they held a measure of prestige in the local
community.
Downhearted previously been the tutors and the royal of whistles,
Bach princes.
It was this connection that led to the great honor of having Prince Heinrich of
Bavaria as Heinrich's Godfather.
Heinrich was not a well child.
He was often absent from school with one illness or another.
Still he made up for the absences by simply working harder.
By doing so,
he proved himself to be an excellent students.
A middle school teacher remembered him as a very keen people whose tireless
application,
burning ambition,
and active participation in class have achieved excellent results.
The man who would go on to persecute the Catholic clergy without mercy grew up
as part of a devout family of believers.
As a youth,
he wrote in his diary,
I would always love God and remain true to the church.
As a teenager,
Heinrich served as an altar boy,
but when war broke out,
he developed,
he desire to serve his country in a military capacity gap party forever
nationalist approved and tried to use his royal contacts to smooth his son's
path to becoming an officer.
However,
the 17 year olds was turned down by the imperial navy due to his short
sightedness.
He therefore,
it turns into the army gaining entry and being sent to officer training school.
But before he had completed his cadet ship,
the board,
it was over.
Unlike the Fiera who he would come to greatly admire.
Hemlock saw none of the carnage of the Great War.
Fast hands.
Hey,
April,
1919 Himmler joins one of the many free corpse army units that winter time ends
to crush the communist movements.
During the next two years,
he served in various paramilitary organizations that were on the march against
democracy,
the shame old treaty of Versailles and Marxists dictatorship.
Young Himmler had been frustrated that he didn't get to [inaudible] on the front
lines during the war,
ins lacking any direction he sought,
a cause that he could embrace and a leader that he could respect him and his
family had not been inherently anti Semetic and is that a 27 but he began
reading the Jew bashing pamphlets that were circulating around Munich.
He also got a hold of the Protocols of the Elders of Zion.
They faked the documents,
the purported,
you contain details of a Jewish wells conspiracy.
Hemlock came of age in a time when the old order of things was in a state of
chaos.
The German people,
they were defeated.
Their economy decimated and their psyche damaged.
Irreparably.
This school was a lot of fear.
There's a lot of depression in the old order.
Hemler beat,
son of a royal tutor would have found a secure place in society,
but now all bets were off.
He would have to forge his own path.
Gerhard Himmler heard instills in his sons the two tonic ideal that the German
Aryan was the master human being.
What Heinrich store on the streets of Munich and the early twenties was the
opposite of Arion and supremacy.
The people were fast sliding into decadence and in morality,
but this was no fault of the German people.
His readings convinced him that the countries' ills could be laid at the feet of
one group,
and that was of course the Jews.
Him Low would spend the rest of his life.
Championing the two tonic ideal is constant refrain when faced with a situation
was what would our forefathers have done in this situation?
Disgusted at what had happened to his beloved German nation.
The young Himmler began making a plan to emigrate on November the 23rd 1921 he
wrote the following in his diary.
Today.
I caught an article from the newspaper about immigration to Peru where I will
end up Spain,
Turkey,
the Baltic countries,
Russia,
Peru.
I often think about it in 10 years time,
I will no longer be in Germany.
Now,
a year later,
he was still in Germany,
but the dream of living abroad,
it was still with him.
In 1922 he inquired at the Soviet embassy about moving to the Ukraine as an
estate manager.
Interestingly,
two decades later,
he would send his death squads into Ukraine to decimate the lands and to wipe
out it's Jewish inhabitants.
For now,
his greatest ambition was to be a peaceful agricultural manager.
Well,
by the ends of 1922 him,
La had completed a degree in agriculture and settled into a job as an
agricultural assistant in a fertilizer factory.
Then in 1923 he joins the Nationalist Socialist Workers Party,
also known as the Nazi party.
He started off as a member of the paramilitary units under [inaudible],
played a part in the unsuccessful beer haul putsch in an attempt to seize power.
The police through several people,
including Hitler himself in prison,
and he was questioned that he was released because of lack of evidence,
but his involvement in the attempted revolts let him to losing his job as an
agricultural analyst with no money coming in.
We had to move back in with his parents around this time and the appears to have
fallen into a depressive state.
He had a few friends and portrayed and aggressive volcanic personality.
The Catholic religion,
which had been so dear to him,
was abandoned,
and the fascination with the occult began to take shape unlike a lot of other
new recruits to the Nazi party,
and that was an off immediately overawed by the presence of Adolf Hitler.
This adoration that he had for the fear of it develops over a long time.
As soon as his nature him let read everything he could about by Hitler,
he came to appreciate him first on an intellectual level,
the worship that would come soon enough.
Z now unemployed to 25 year olds,
but again,
putting all of his energies into the cause of a national socialism.
He's are calling the position of secretary for Greg.
All Strasser right pharmacist from land short who was standing as a candidate
for the Reichstag in return for a salary of 120 Reichsmarks.
He traveled around the Lower Bavaria on his motorcycle and gave inflammatory
speeches against Jews and communists.
Strasser was a Nazi party member who was attempting to wrest control of the
organization from the imprisoned Hitler believing that he would succeed him let
supported Strasser in this internal power struggle and the other 1920s the
notoriously shy Heinrich found frau line and us from Bromberg named Margo Tall,
blonde and blue eyed.
She fits the Teutonic ideal and matched him Liz ideal image of Germanic
womanhood.
The couple were married on July 3rd,
1928 with Margo bringing a sizeable dowry to the Union.
The financial windfall enabled Heinrich to realize his dream of owning his own
piece of land and they purchased a chicken farm not far from Munich during this
time,
heavily managed to rise rapidly in standing within the party.
By 1926 he was deputy had a variety of propaganda and then deputy Reichsfuhrer
ss I then Hitler had been released from prison,
brushed aside the internal threat from Strasser and published his tone mine camp
Himmler effortlessly switched his allegiance back to Hitler.
He devoured mine camp commenting that it contained an extraordinary number of
truths very quickly Himmler's loyalty to Hitler.
It became absolute.
By the mid 1920 set,
Lou came to the realization that he was in need of special protection force.
He needed a squad of men who gave him unquestioned loyalty and we're even
prepared to march against their brothers if need be.
So it had such a force.
No one was as fervently devoted in.
Therefore,
so eminently suitors has Heinrich Himmler on January the second 1929 hit or
appointed him low to the position of Reichsfuhrer ss.
But that time,
the SS was a small division of the larger essay which was under the headship of
Armstrong.
VSA was hitless private taught me the fighting quality of its men was
questionable,
but Ron saw its strength coming from force of numbers.
In contrast,
the SS was a far more elite force.
It's members wore black peaked cabs emblazoned with a skull along with black
bordered swastika arm bands.
This new position,
it was ideal for him.
Since his youth,
he had been fascinated by the elites,
praetorian guards that were the elites protection force of Rem and embarrass.
Now we have the opportunity to craft his own modern day Praetorian guard.
He immediately began putting his own stamp on the ss he had to bell's buckles,
made that were scripted with the words ss man.
Loyalty is Dayana.
He also came up with a succinct motto for his men.
Be More than you seem when him assumed leadership VSS number around 200 men.
A year later,
it had grown to just over a thousand.
By June of 1934 it had swollen to 50,000 men in 1931 him that created a unit
within that unit and it was called one C and it was put under the leadership of
a rising star called Reinhardt Heidrick later to become the secret service.
This was the organ by which Hitler could have undercover surveillance undertaken
within the party.
Okay.
By 1934 the essay on the Strom had become redundant now that he was chancellor,
he had no need for a bunch of street thugs.
In fact,
his association with them,
it was bound to be damaging to his career.
It was time to break this private army up.
Him was delighted with the news that the essay along with its commander and
strong,
we're about to be dealt with for five years.
He had been a subordinates to the uncouth and disorganized rom whom he
considered his social inferior.
The threw himself into planning the overthrow of the essay.
That history would recall as the night of the long knives documents before just
to show that the essay was planning a coup and him look personally took these
documents to hit not immediately.
Death lists were drawn up containing the names of essay leaders as well as any
others who were seen by him.
Low rent,
Heidrick has threats to their growing palate.
At the top of that list was Ernst wrong when Rome was taken into custody,
Hillary was actually in favor of commuting the death sentence as long term
colleague,
but he was browbeaten by Himmler and Heidrick into eliminating him.
This was in calling with hemlock underlying nature.
He was a man who was completely devoid of scruples,
lacking any of the normal inhibitions or pangs of conscious that would cause
others to pause in such actions.
Theorists torments and murders if the night of the long knives were carried out
by him,
those assess their leader.
Well,
he was a major beneficiary off this operation in the wake of the purging of the
essay him that took over headship of the Gestapo from um,
and Garing around that same time him,
the order,
the death of Gerhard Strasser,
the man he had earlier supported his Nazi party leader and it had been his
employer.
Yeah.
By 1935 hemlock was in a position of great power within the Nazi state as well
as heading the SS and the Gestapo.
He was also in of the entire German police force.
This allows him to participate in cabinet meetings with all the rights and
privileges afforded a minister of the Reich.
On October the 11th,
1936 similar gave a speech in front of the Academy of German law in it,
he made it clear how he was going to run the countries,
police and defense forces,
whether on us our actions conflict with a particular article or subsection is a
matter of complete indifference to me and the fulfillments of my duty.
I do precisely what I can answer for them in my work for Fiora and nation and
what equates with healthy common sense,
whether or not others whined about a breach of the law is no concern to me.
Hello was only accepted the very best.
Did you tell nick men into the ss the organization was to be a racial elite
class?
Hemlock made sure that he saw a photo of every applicants.
The meticulously scans them in search of anything that might give evidence of
impurity.
Once he found his perfect specimens,
he intended to do what he could to ensure that there were more of them.
And so on October the 28th 1939 he issued his procreation audit to the SS.
It was the highest duty of women and girls.
Do you conceive children by soldiers of the SS before they went into battle?
In other words,
if a female did not submit to the sexual demands of an ss man,
she was guilty of treason to the state and look,
became obsessed with the idea of procreating.
The worlds with pure Ariens and order went out so that every ss man was the
father.
At least one child,
he considered monogamy to be a sin.
His men were allowed to have several wives in order to be able to father as many
future heroes as possible.
Under him,
the SS became much more than a personal body guard for the fear,
and La had been charged with restoring the nation to health.
This task required reading the country of racial impurity.
To do this,
the assets would go through community after community and cleanse it of Jews,
free masons and Jesuits,
but Himmler how soon extended the list of undesirables to include Slavs,
Gypsies,
homosexuals,
Jehovah's Witnesses,
and communists.
When Hitler invaded Russia in 1941 hymnal or provided actions squad.
So you would follow up the regular army as it conquered the lambs.
Their job was to say gold.
All Jews,
communists and Gypsies Himmler insured,
that is men kept meticulous records of their activities.
One of the squad commanders had recorded 90,000 killings and just the last few
months of 1941 these Moscow murders,
however,
presented a problem that Himmler pat to provide a solution for having to kill so
many people each day was proving challenging for the psyches of the soldiers
doing the work.
The question that entered his mind was,
was there a more efficient way to kill that did not lead to such demoralization?
Now,
of course,
there was no question in his mind that the course of mass murder was morally,
socially and politically correct.
For years,
he had drilled two simple rules into the minds of his assess.
Firstly,
the Futura was always right and secondly,
the end justifies the means.
He presented the mass extermination as a monumental secular mission that is men
were privileged to be fulfilling after personally watching the execution of 200
Jews near Minsk.
He said,
it is the cause of the great man to step over corpses.
In the summer of 1941 homeless summons the common dawns of the Auschwitz
concentration camp Rudolph halls to a meeting in Berlin.
He informs him that the fear had ordered the final solution of the Jewish
question BSS.
He told Hos or to carry out that order and he had selected outfits as the prime
location to do it.
Austin out of Eichmann where to organize the genocide,
but Himmler was the man in charge under him and watchful gaze.
The concentration camps with outfits as the shining model became incredibly
efficient death factories.
Those passing through the gates of the camp where we did with those selected
going directly to the gas chambers in less than 15 minutes,
they were dead victims of the highly poisonous gas,
a Cyclin B for those who are considered fit for work,
that death would come from exhaustion or starvation.
Himmler paid a personal visit to Auschwitz in 1942 he watched as victims were
selected and to watch through a spy hole in the gas chamber door.
As the executions were carried out.
He did not comment on what he saw,
which was assigned to commandant Hos that he was happy with what he witnessed.
He wins on to inspect the rest of the camp during which time Hoss campaigns
about the squalid conditions and the dangers of disease to as men and let's
stopped him in mid sentence and declared.
I don't want to hear any more about your difficulties for an ss officer that are
no difficulties,
his duty is always to remove difficulties himself as soon as they arise.
How you do it is for you to figure out not me.
By mid 1944 the tide of war per turn downs,
the writing was on the walls for the Nazi regime.
Yes,
him and his unwavering loyalty to add,
I've hit load were still intact.
This being the case,
historians have noted that it does seem odd that with his massive spine that
work,
he did not have advanced warnings of the July 20th,
1944 plot to kill Hitler.
Some of you even speculated that he was involved in some way.
Now.
It is true that three days before the attack he turned down a written Gestapo
request for permission to arrest.
Two of the main plot is it's also clear that the ruthlessness with which the SS
persecution machine went into action after the attack was not matched with.
It's usually impeccable standard of surveillance before it.
It is probable that him that did not intend to portray Hitler on July the 20th
of 1944 but that betrayal it was to come and it would manifest itself on the
fear as birthday April the 20th 1945 on that day,
Himmler was a guest along with other high ranking Nazi is it what must surely
have been one of the most macabre birthday parties in history?
It was held in the underground bunker that was there's final hideout situated in
the heart of ravaged Berlin.
Hitler was unaware that him and I had a second later that day with an emissary
from the world congress of Jewry.
He proposed that the Jews and the national socialists bury the hatchet and the
concentration camp inmates would be handed over to the Red Cross just a few days
earlier.
He had given orders that no camp survivors were to fall into enemy hands and no
camps were to be surrendered.
His about face was clearly a matter of expediency in and attempts to minimize
the ire of the allies when they discovered the horrors that have been taking
place under his watch.
Three days later,
him the held talks with the Swedish diplomat counter full could burn a dotake.
Yeah.
He presented a surprising office saying that's in order to save Germans from the
full force of a Russian invasion.
He was prepared to surrender the western front,
but not the eastern front handle.
The believed that he could negotiate directly with President Eisenhower and
wondered out loud whether he should shake the president's hand or offer him a
Nazi salute.
Of course,
Himmler's clandestine visits were meant to be top secret.
However,
somehow they got leaked to the media runs on April the 28th for London's BBC
broadcasts that Himmler was claiming that Hitler was dead and that he was his
successor in the Berlin bunk.
There was monitoring the airwaves and this news,
well,
it seemed,
found its way to the fear up.
Hitler was dumbstruck.
He could accept betrayal from anyone else but never from his loyal him that he
called it the most monstrous betrayal in world history and he immediately
ordered him less arrest,
but within days Hitler,
he was dead.
The victim of his own hands
on May,
the first Hemena mass with headless admiraal called donuts at the naval barracks
at [inaudible] donuts was wary.
Even though Himmler had been deposed,
there was no telling how much allegiance the men of the SS would still give to
him.
Him Lo was shown his letter of dismissal,
ignoring it,
so you congratulated on it's on his appointments and offered to work with them
as his second in commands.
Don,
it's declined.
The using was over and Daimler it was allowed to walk away.
He now resolves to Kevin's a hiding and bide his time before coming back to lead
as all powerful assets on a search to up on May.
The 20 seconds with the war over in Germany.
Under allied occupation of British patrols spotted a group of ragged looking man
outside of Hamburg.
One of them were short,
thin man with a black eye patch,
told them his name was Heinrich Pittson gun and then produced forged identity
papers.
He was dressed as an ordinary German soldier.
The seven men were in fact Himmler and his body guards.
The British guards took the group into custody and placed them in a prisoner of
war camp just outside of Bremen.
It didn't take long for the proud Himmler to chief under the common treatments
that he was receiving as merely a captured soldier.
After a few days,
he requested in an audience with the camp commander expecting to be treated with
newfound dignity.
Hemler announced his true identity,
but rather than being respected for his position as the Nazi number two man,
his captors treated him with contempt.
He was forced to stripped completely and as captains of 24 hour watch to prevent
a suicide the following day him lo was brought before the camp commander
differentt derogation in mouth.
He had secrets it as an MP with poison which had been issued tool top Nazis and
which they always carried with them.
A body search was ordered and when the doctor tried to examine him in his mouth,
he bit down on the ampule.
The enraged British tried desperately to clear the poison from his system,
but it was no good within 12 minutes,
Himmler was dead.
So I really hope you enjoyed that episode of biographics.
If you did this,
a couple of things you could do right now.
One is hit that like button below.
Also,
if you want more stuff like this,
we put out brand new videos every Monday and every Thursday,
so hit that subscribe button below and subscribe button doesn't do what it used
to on Youtube.
If you actually want to get a notification about these videos,
please do hit that bell button next to the subscribe button and that'll send you
a notification every time,
every Monday and Thursday when we put out a new video.
Also,
if you want to watch something else right now,
stuff from the archive over there on the rice,
and as always,
thank you for watching.
[inaudible].